[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
mirvat rifaat aliyeva présidente de la
maison de leatherhead gens à paris vous
est aussi secrétaire général de
l'association des amis de l azerbaïdjan
en france à vos côtés laurent leylekian
analystes politiques bonsoir vous êtes
un spécialiste de l'asie mineure et du
caucase sud bonsoir donc à tous les deux
et merci d'être avec nous bien venu sur
l'antenne berthet france après les armes
donc place au processus de paix à la
reconstruction avec un coup de fil
important aujourd'hui entre emmanuel
macron et vladimir poutine conversation
portant sur plusieurs points dont la
résolution des problèmes humanitaires et
la préservation des églises et
monastères chrétien on parlera tout à
l'heure des problèmes humanitaires
concernant ces lieux de culte c'est
vital pour les arméniens étaient
souillés pour moi sans doute oui
pardonnez-moi laurent à l'ailé thierry
henry oui ça fait partie de précisément
ce que les populations locales cherchent
à préserver c'est à dire non seulement
leur existence mais également leur vie
culturelle leur vie cultuelle césar
médias là ne viennent pas d'armé ni ils
ont habité là de plus tant et donc ils
veulent préserver des églises qui date
du viiie du 10ème siècle des lieux très
ancien et finalement ce qu'il souhaite
c'est que monsieur reviennent pas à leur
patrimoine architectural ce qui est
arrivé au patrimoine d'autres régions
limitrophes on peut penser par exemple
on a rich evans ou aujourd'hui on
provoque une seule et des arménienne
alors qu'il y en avait des dizaines et
des dizaines et en 2004 il ya eu cette
métropole de djoulfa qui a été
totalement rasé à ras le sol donc on
pourra plus aucune trace il ya un camp
militaire en place c'est précisément ce
que redoutent ces populations et qui
souhaitent et bien vivre tout simplement
vivre normalement comme elles l'ont
toujours fait sur cette période alors on
entend les arméniens qui craignent un
génocide culturel on sait que pour
l'azerbaïdjan ces terres sont une
question existe
en ciel bas coûts a d'ailleurs le
précise reconquis de larges territoires
sous contrôle arménien avec cet accord
on peut se demander quelle attitude va
maintenant être adopté ce que les
américains ont obtenu gain de cause
vont-ils tendre la main aux arméniens
may vary fait ailier va oui pense pas un
merci de votre invitation aujourd'hui je
me réjouis bien sûr de l'accord de paix
qui a été signé le 10 novembre dernier
sous l'égide de la russie entre
l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie
dans mon esprit c'est accord de paix ne
vise pas simplement à mettre fin à une
guerre qui a éclaté en septembre 2020
entre bakou et erevan
il s'agit bien de régler un conflit
vieux de plus de trente ans et parvenir
de façon définitive à une paix durable
dans l'intérêt du peuple azerbaïdjanais
et arménien à la force de paix de paix
mais fin bien sûr pour l'azerbaïdjan à
ses 30 ans d'impuissance de la
communauté internationale et de l'onu
et plus précisément l'impuissance du
groupe de ministres
la guerre était malheureusement
inévitable car depuis 1994 la région
pour l'essai il nous faut stopper
il y avait très souvent la violation de
cessez le feu qui faisait de mort et de
deux côtés bien sûr et toute la faune et
internationales voyez venir la guerre
sans forcément réagir malheureusement
selon l'accord l'azerbaïdjan pourra
conserver tous ses gains territoriaux y
compris la deuxième ville du grande
ville du haut karabagh choucha une huile
que la population atteint la genèse
avaient été obligés de fuir durant la
guerre du haut karabagh les forces
arméniennes devront céder le contrôle
d'une série d'autres territoires
dc 1er décembre pour moi c'était que le
respect du droit international bafoué
depuis 1993 ces territoires étant
internationalement reconnue comme
faisant partie de l'azerbaïdjan
l'azerbaïdjan n'a jamais été dans un
logique de guerre malgré les
intimidations et les provocations sans
cesse de la part du gouvernement
arménien elle a simplement demandé que
le droit international soit appliqué
dans un monde aujourd'hui de plus en
plus complexes chacun doit prendre ses
responsabilités et agir pour une paix
définitive dans la région aujourd'hui il
faut bâtir la paix quand vous avez dit
elle c'est à ce à quoi veut s'employer
le président de l'azerbaïdjan ilham
alief le pays et le peuple de cette
région et en particulier les populations
du haut karabagh mérite de vivre
ensemble et je les entends du bien
évidemment parler de patrons - culturel
depuis 30 ans l'harmonie health a
systématiquement et délibérément détruit
et a intégré le caractère les origines
autres - culturel religieux de
l'azerbaïdjan on voit bien les images
aujourd'hui de mosquées détruites et
transformant les tables par l'arménie
cela confirme et bien elle que l'arménie
a délibéremment avaient librement
systématiquement détruit les cultes les
lieux de culte les patrimoines culturel
azerbaïdjanais
je voyais un laurent leylekian a levé
les yeux au ciel vous partagez pas
vraiment le le point de vue de devenir
varie fatali eva non évidemment
bien sûr que non vous savez vous avez
des gens qui vivaient sur cette paire et
qui avait construit une démocratie faut
quand même remplacé les choses dans mon
dos dans la vérité si vous voulez des
mots l'azerbaïdjan est une dictature
il suffit de prendre les classements
internationaux qui ne respectent pas les
droits de ses propres citoyens
et comment voulez-vous qu'elles
respectent les droits de personne que
son leader a désigné comme des chiens
que son leader si vous voulez pour
lesquelles son leader là
les f-16 continûment à la haine depuis
30 ans je rappelle le cas de cet
officier qui était décapité quand même
pendant son sommeil
lors d'un exercice de l'otan en 2004 un
officier arménien voilà donc comme comme
tout le monde moi je me félicite de
l'accord de paix parce que l'accord de
paix des morts en moins des deux côtés
d'ailleurs et je me félicite également
que la france et la russie
et peut-être les états unis demain cet
accord a assuré la sécurité des
populations arméniennes de ce district
qui est le haut karabagh tient
déclaration d'indépendance
tout comme réserver le genre en
conformité avec le droit international
en 1991 trois jours après les herbes et
des gens pour les arbitres jean s'est
séparé de l'urss et bien le karabagh
séparer de l'azerbaïdjan comme la
constitution le prévoyait voilà et je
pense d'ailleurs que une bonne une bonne
mise en pratique des comme si vous
voulez du doubs enfin vous une bonne
mise en pratique du droit humanitaire
qui permettrait aux populations locales
de vivre en sécurité sur leurs terres
ancestrales à ces populations
arméniennes obligera à quelque part les
les parties de minsk la russie et la
france est peut-être les etats-unis à
prendre langue qui a discuté avec les
autorités kabaria parce qu'aujourd'hui
ce sont les autorités qui leur mariage
si tout simplement d'un verre pratiques
vont recevoir ces réfugiés ils vont
devoir les réinstaller sur leurs terres
en tout cas sur ce qu'il en reste
puisque effectivement madame fatah
liéval a rappelé aujourd'hui
l'azerbaïdjan à s'ils voulaient pris la
main sur une partie de la zone de
sécurité qui offrait un karabagh mais
occupe aujourd'hui une partie du
karabagh proprement dit qui s'était
séparé démocratiquement de l'azerbaïdjan
ou ferment ce référendum de 1992
donc voilà il va falloir maintenant
accepter le processus politique c'est à
dire de la discussion sur le statut du
karabagh au delà de la guerre et par un
processus de négociation diplomatique
vous dites il va falloir l'accepter il
n'empêche à beaucoup d'amertume côté
arménien beaucoup rêveraient d'ailleurs
de voir le nikol pashinian démissionner
de manière pacifique du poste de premier
ministre
on a vu des maisons brûlées et un plutôt
que de les laisser à leurs ennemis la
mission russe lui maintien de paix ne va
pas être chose aisée
mir varie fatale ieva savez je comprends
parfaitement digéré une défaite est
l'une des épreuves les plus difficiles
dans la vie d'une nation moi même étant
réfugié plutôt déplacé du d'une région
avoisinante audio à la barre j'ai vécu
les atrocités de cette guerre j'ai vu
des gens mourir devant les yeux
j'ai quitté ma maison ma ville natale
sous les bombardements à unia j'ai perdu
de gens de ma famille mais ce n'est pas
pour autant que j'ai de la haine pour le
pour le peuple arménien ce n'est pas
pour autant que j'ai demandé de la bonne
chance j'ai juste voulu toujours la
justice pour le peuple azerbaïdjanais ce
qui a été bien évidemment fait avec cet
accord d'une du 10 novembre dernier
l'offre aujourd'hui la russie est
déployée déploie ses soldats dans le
voka la barre pour maintenir justement
pour le respect de cette trêve de
respect de ce cessez le feu
cela va être difficile pour deux peuples
qui vivait bien ensemble
avant j'ai vu dans votre reportage
également parler de la religion
c'était pauvre la personne ne parlait de
la religion c'est lui jamais été un
conflit d'ordre de leur religion de
religion donc pour la serva
il est un pays laïc où ils vivent
plusieurs ethnies de différentes
confessions donc ce cet accord pour moi
peut amener la paix dans la région
bien évidemment si il est soutenu par
toute la diaspora arménienne
aujourd'hui la diaspora arménienne fait
la pression dans le monde entier surtout
en france aujourd'hui également la
france à prendre ouvertement parti pour
l'arménie
ce qui déçoit bien sûr le peuple
azerbaïdjanais vous sachant que la
france a voté quatre mots solution de
l'onu qui demande le retrait immédiat et
inconditionnel des troupes arméniennes
des territoires azerbaïdjanais donc
l'azerbaïdjan défend aujourd'hui a
défendu l son droit légitime et à
récupérer c'est qu'il ya aparté noro à
l'élection au coeur des discussions
entre vladimir poutine et emmanuel
macron aujourd'hui également la
situation humanitaire et préoccupe
beaucoup
vladimir poutine qui a proposé la
coopération avec la france et les états
unis pour bien qu'on comprenne combien
de familles ont dû fuir dans quel état
de précarité se retrouvent les habitants
de cette zone
alors comme une famille je ne saurais
vous le dire combien de personnes
peut-être plus il y avait au karabagh et
dans les zones avoisinantes sous
contrôle de la république karabagh
environ cent cinquante mille personnes
on estime que les deux tiers ont fui
c'est à dire 100 mille personnes qui se
sont retrouvées en arménie voisine à
goris ou dans d'autres régions par
exemple avec tennis donc il ya cent
mille personnes qui doivent revenir mais
qui reviendront au pas par tout d'abord
elles ne reviendront pas sous contrôle
dans les zones sous contrôle
azerbaïdjanais
parce que leur vie ne serait pas assurée
tout simplement
et puis elles ne reviendront pas non
plus dans la partie du karabagh
proprement dit qui est également ce
contrôle azerbaïdjanais en particulier
le statut de chouchou de shoushi qui est
pour l'instant extrêmement indécis où la
ville de ha de route au sud
donc ça fait beaucoup de personnes à
reloger sur un ferry
ware qui ne représente plus que
peut-être le tiers de ce qu'il
représentait avec un des shows de
logements tout simplement il n'y a pas
assez de maison il va falloir en
reconstruire que ce soit à malte uni à
magda quête qui sont les zones
éventuellement très proche de la
frontière donc la force de maintien de
la paix est tout à fait tout à fait
souhaitable et effectivement il faut
rendre grâce à cette présence
cette présence russe même si elle
extrêmement ambigu et mais il ya
beaucoup de genres à faire revenir et
dans les conditions matérielles
extrêmement difficile puisque la guerre
a détruit non seulement les positions
militaires mais un très grand nombre
d'infrastructures civiles et parfois
délibérément d'ailleurs voilà j'aurai vu
des gens je rejoins madame fatale yema
en disant que ce conflit n'a jamais été
et n'est pas de nature religieuse
c'est réellement un conflit de
légitimité nationale et c'est aussi un
confit de valeur puisque encore une fois
vous aviez d'un côté un état qui donc la
république du haut karabagh qui avait
tient et ya construit une certaine
démocratie en dépit de conditions
matérielles extrêmement dur qui était
enclavé non reconnu et les arbitres jean
qui est très autoritaire quand même vous
galop mais zéro connaître merci à tous
les deux tout cas on arrive à la fin du
débat on voulait pas repartir sur un un
débat de fond merci en tout cas tous les
deux on a bien compris vos points de vue
respectifs mais un vernis et pardon mire
varient fatiha et laurent les lectures
merci à vous deux